standing in front the right here he's
taking photo he's even better he's
parked he's taking a selfie I gotta I
gotta this is gonna be a bit of a tricky
no you tricky shop see I can do it yeah
perfect
can we've got all this money but nobody
knows who we are
and without that said what's the point
what even is the point we got the
lifestyles of the rich but not the
famous true look at our cars they're
great but then these guys these chumps
don't don't know our escapades hey it's
us look they don't even care
this is muck this is how I think I just
walk about on top of your car hmm okay
but it really helps me think but I think
I've gone better yet I'll walk clean
through your car
did you see the Oscars and there was
that selfie that got really famous oh
why don't we just take lots of cool
selfies but can we go a little bit more
extreme than that because we want to be
really famous well yeah we could we
could take extreme selfies then said
we're after a cracking start to one ha
ha ha perfect yeah it's an see this lady
knows what's up
right where are the lots of people serve
where are their loads of people
[Music]
right over the wrong one chef I think I
may have got you though yes we did reset
we're never gonna get famous running
over the wrong laws chasing that's
that's me it's not illegal to take
photos of people getting run over it
seems that's good too though we here we
see a rare life guard in his natural
habitat I just missed it Oh too late
oh sorry oh damn it I think he's hurt
all right let's try again I got a check
on the lifeguard yeah he's he's hurt
he's hurt stand in front right here he's
taking photo he's even better he's
perfect he's taking a selfie I gotta I
gotta this is gonna be a bit of a tricky
no you tricky shot perfect I'm gonna
loop around so I'm bailing at the
correct side okay I see you I see the
setup this is too delicious yeah because
that way I'll be bailing at the correct
side of the car they're already
suspicious of you oh no they're bailing
they're choosing it they still in shock
yeah oh here we go
all right oh it's good let's go pick a
fight with me huh quick get a selfie
this here we go what's on this guy
devastation all the money but the fires
all right that's a good kid and the
selling that that was that's gonna that
doesn't make us famous yeah this is good
this is good closer closer I know is
worth it it was a great photo
hany pals ami pals I've arrived perfect
I got it okay
Oh God Oh
sit onto them pretty quickly it was
worth it listening fire friends they
were talking about how they were gonna
get baked later
crud again you just killed me
everybody double coke car double cop car
seven all right go for double cop car oh
we've got a bit early yo god you're in
trouble
happy in a bigger trouble hey hey buddy
hey buddy shotgun smile buddy smile
yeah I'm still good
oh no I'm down I'm on fire there we go
sticky bomb is on Mac oh that's really
good we can we can time it if you climb
on top of that oh I didn't know you're
gonna do it oh I didn't mean to
no I was trying to turn the siren uh-huh
I'll plant one up this is genius this is
Jeanie are you gonna are you gonna
you're gonna drive into the middle of a
group of people and resonate it all
right like here's a group right here
guys you mind if I just leave this here
okay so we're it what's the plan exactly
you see you creeping in just gonna leave
this here no one's gonna mind right yeah
it's fine you guys can you watch this
car that's great okay okay can you now a
little bit get more in camera designate
you [ __ ] you tell me did we get a shot
we might have gotten the shot Wow
so said I've got a plan why don't you
pile up a bunch of car somewhere can you
do me like can you cause a a diversion a
distraction of sorts and get a pileup
I'll get a plane crash the plane into
the cars everything will blow up and you
sell fear I'm ready for the shot we got
more people join here comes here I come
lovely oh man hopefully what my angle
was maybe it's not quite right okay one
more time I'll go get one more play okay
I see a plane coming in oh oh I think
that muscular that might be it all right
I turned the engine completely off as
well I smell oh hey oh geez you really
hit the grade hard there found there we
go you left the door open sorry man God
born in a barn yes oh why is there
explosives on my plane what are you
doing what are you planning to keep
keeping an eye on things I was wondering
if maybe we could take an extreme selfie
as I parachute through the flames okay
I'm just gonna document this evidence
for the police there we go yeah good one
okay I'm jumping out of this helicopter
I've gone okay I'm not ready I'm ready
I'm ready hey Danny it's gonna take a
little bit time oh dude that was so good
I'm ready
all right I'm cheesing out of here I
think I need to come in a bit steeper
here we go coming in coming in I see you
I see you
sorry I'm fine a guy a guy you are you
were gonna love you were just gonna love
this photo
okay I'm gonna deer
I'm good idea okay for a final for a
final one I want you to I'm gonna stand
just here by the runway with my selfie
camera ready to go I want you to fly low
level upside down oh we should probably
should yeah we don't need to do the Yolo
all right here we go this is good
oh god it doesn't it doesn't stay
upside-down hey sir it really doesn't
oh he doesn't like I'll slide down
flying whoa okay okay tell I don't know
I can I can I can try that again
oh bring it in I see you coming in I see
you coming in okay oh great snap did it
save it don't know did it save the snap
said I'm shocked at the quality of the
selfies without today we did well did
really well
oh yeah yeah and you know we flew like
birds at times yeah a few people died in
the making of these selfies and to them
I salute them you know I decently than
they did good although some of them were
jerks someone whom other bloody jerks
overall it was a rising success I would
say I don't know what this one is
you've done us proud Doris if I'm gonna
let you have the ultimate the ultimate
selfie I make sure you get this one okay
I'm ready I'm ready to the selfie okay
so here it is here it is
all right oh what a shot I'll take that
cracking show
you
[Music]